cheese butter is the delicious gourmet
cheese melt that blends four indulgent
cheeses and seasoned butter i love this
stuff perfect on bread bagels sandwiches
veggies and more you'll get 15 off at
cheesebutter.com pacman the link is down
below
let's start today with joe biden's first
state of the union address many of you
wrote to me you said david i remember in
2021 joe biden gave a state of the union
address yes he basically did except in a
president's first year in office that
first joint address to the house and
senate is not called a state of the
union address so this was the first
state of the union address
by name
but the second one in spirit i guess we
would say overall
it was okay it was okay i mean i'll give
you kind of my more
wrap-up overall review after we look at
some clips but i think joe biden sort of
struck the right note and tone overall
and in particular with ukraine russia
that was probably the strongest part and
he opened with that
there was a bunch in the middle that was
very so so and a lot of kind of vague
throwing out things he's going to do
which will obviously never see the light
of day with absolutely no explanation as
to how some of those things would even
be possible and we will get to that but
overall this is you have to remember
this is a particularly weaponized
republican party whose goal is just stop
biden at any opportunity stop just don't
let him do anything and given that
context it is difficult to put together
a speech that uh republicans in any any
real way are going to be satisfied by
but let's just get right into it uh joe
biden opening up
with a statement of solidarity with
ukraine
six days ago
russia's vladimir putin sought to shake
the very foundations of the free world
thinking he could make it bend
to his menacing ways
but he badly miscalculated
he thought he could roll into ukraine
and the world would roll over
instead
he met with a mall a wall of strength he
never anticipated or imagined he met
ukrainian people
so the tone here was the right tone and
again he he started strong and this was
really one of the better parts of the
speech continuing on to talk about
new restrictions sanctions limitations
on russia and russian oligarchs and
again also played very well with the
crowd tonight
i say to the russian oligarchs and the
corrupt leaders who built billions of
dollars off this violent regime no more
the united states
i mean it
the united states
department of justice is assembling a
dedicated task force to go after the
crimes of the russian oligarchs
we're joining with european allies to
find and seize their yachts their luxury
apartments their private jets
we're coming for you or ill-begotten
gains and tonight i'm announcing that we
will join our allies in closing off
american airspace to all russian flights
further isolating russia and adding
additional squeeze on their economy
so more restrictions and those well
received and the restrictions make sense
the only caveat is we we do want to make
sure that all americans that are in
russia can get home obviously the
signals to those in ukraine for a while
have been get out
but we want to make sure that americans
in russia can get home but all popular
sensible things to be doing
and
again
republicans basically clapping for just
about everything joe biden said on the
issue of russia ukraine united states
and our allies will defend every inch of
territory that is nato territory for the
full force of our collective power every
single inch
okay so that stuff very strong and very
popular with the entire crowd and then
it became a more typical state of the
union address republicans for example
booing
when joe biden correctly points out
donald trump's tax cuts
disproportionately benefited the rich
they did and republicans boo either
because they don't believe it or because
they don't like that it's being pointed
out
unlike the two trillion dollar tax cut
passed in the previous administration
that benefited the top one percent of
americans the american rescue plan
[Music]
[Applause]
the american rescue plan
helped working people and left no one
behind
so a bit of a strange false start there
from chuck schumer but uh the
republicans booing joe biden's comment
about who benefited from donald trump's
tax cuts although what joe biden said
was perfectly accurate at then at an
almost immediately uh subsequent point
joe biden talks about what has been
record job growth under the biden
administration and of course it is true
and we can flesh that out further by
talking about this sort of unique
coveted recovery period in which joe
biden started his uh
presidency needless to say at one point
the camera points to mitch mcconnell and
mccon mcconnell looks like he had some
bad clams uh before the event upon
hearing about record job growth
we created jobs lots of jobs in fact our
economy created over
6.5 million new jobs just last year
more jobs
in one year
than ever before in the history of the
united states of america
the economy grew at a rate of 5.7 last
year the strongest growth rate in 40
years
and the first step in bringing
fundamental change to our economy that
hasn't worked for working people in this
nation for too long
for the past 40 years and there's mitch
mcconnell who just looks like something
was wrong with the muscles if you know
what i mean at dinner beforehand um then
joe biden started getting into some of
sort of the the general policy ideas and
a lot of them made for okay rhetoric but
i'm going to be honest with you guys a
lot of these are basically
impossibilities let's listen to the
first one
that means make more cars and
semiconductors in america
more infrastructure and innovation in
america
more goods moving faster and cheaper in
america
more jobs where you can earn a good
living in america
instead of relying on foreign supply
chains let's make it in america
lord
economists
you know
i think this is one of those things
where it this is the epitome of the
absurdity of american politics
republicans who say they're all about
build and buy american are mostly just
sitting
after joe biden says we're going to
build and buy americans so first of all
i thought republicans wanted that and
then all of a sudden they're sitting
down and it's just political trash
at the same time we have an economy
based
on not building american and what i mean
by that is
decades ago the decision was made
implicitly it's not that someone one day
said let's structure our entire economy
on cheap stuff from china and other
countries nobody said that
but through cumulative decisions about
labor and about outsourcing and about
trade the collective implicit decision
was made we would rather pay less for
stuff
but get it from places like china and to
do the build and buy american thing that
joe biden is talking about
it would raise prices on those things in
the united states it just it would and
it would take a minimum eight to ten
years to start making a lot of those
changes so i'm not saying it's good or
bad i'm pointing out
the absurdity of a president saying
it's going to be great when we do this
thing which all of us over the last 40
years have decided not to do we've
actually done the opposite through our
trade and other regulations and
agreements
but also it's something republicans
claim to want but they don't cheer when
joe biden says it it's like the those 25
seconds are the epitome of everything
that's sort of broken with american
politics now the most vile moment of the
entire speech and we will focus in on
this more later was when joe biden was
talking
about his son beau who died of cancer
and lauren bobert yells out
disgustingly you've been there
i've been in and out of iraq and
afghanistan over 40 times
these burn pits that incinerate waste
the waste of war
medical
and hazards material jet fuel and so
much more
and they come home many of the world's
fittest and best trained warriors in the
world
never the same
headaches numbness dizziness
a cancer that would put them in a
flag-draped coffin
i know
one of those so uh
one of those soldiers was my son major
yeah that was um that was lauren
beaubert and we're going to talk about
that a little later one of the most the
most disgusting moment i ever remember
from any state of the union um joe biden
then talking about corporations and the
wealthy paying higher taxes and
elizabeth warren liked it looking to
punish anybody but let's make
corporations and wealthy americans start
paying their fair share
look
last year
last year
so elizabeth warren liking that one
understandingly understandably then a
sort of kind of like a muted we've done
pretty well and are ready to kind of
start moving on from covid not like the
huge mission accomplished but sort of
one for more than two years covet has
impacted every decision in our lives
and the life of this nation
and i know you're tired frustrated and
exhausted
that doesn't even count
close to a million people
who sit at a dining room table or a
kitchen table
look at an empty chair
because they lost somebody
but i also know this
because of the progress we've made
because of your resilience
and the tools that we have been provided
by this congress
tonight i can say we're moving forward
safely
back to no no more normal routines
we've reached a new moment in the fight
against covet 19. so a sort of soft
victory declaration which i think is is
okay it's what was expected and it's
it's basically
uh
warranted by the numbers that we are
seeing at another point joe biden
talking about the importance of
funding police funding police all agree
the answer is not to defund the police
it's to fund the police
so some on the left uh uh taking that as
a direct attack on the progressive
movement but the truth is the the
majority of the progressive movement
doesn't actually want to defund the
police we want to fix the police and and
uh that's that's the reality um lastly
joe biden again finishing strong on the
topic of uh ukraine and uh go get him go
get him the final line of the night
i've come to report on the state of the
nation the state of the union and my
report is this the state of the union is
strong because you the american people
are strong
we are stronger today
we are stronger today than we were a
year ago
and we'll be stronger a year from now
than we are today
this is our moment
to meet and overcome the challenges of
our time and we will
as one people one america the united
states of america
god bless you all
and may god protect our troops
thank you
go get him
go get him seemingly uh apparently
related to vladimir putin so okay my my
honest rating if i just say this is what
what it was with normal standards right
i mean trump really threw off our
barometer but with normal standards this
was probably a b
uh the opening ukraine section was good
it was the right tone the entire speech
was probably the right tone and energy
there were endless disjointed
transitions that were extraordinarily
abrupt a lot of very vague ideas thrown
out at one point joe biden saying we're
gonna crack down on people charging
customers too much for for things
like wait are you suggesting price
controls like that that's a really big
deal what are you talking about are you
proposing legislation
absolutely no idea and i understand it's
a state of the union you don't lay out
everything in detail but there were so
many of those things thrown out which
are obviously never going to see the
light of day so i would give it a b
overall with many elements that were
what was needed
given the situation in ukraine and
russia not made easier overall by the
fact that the republican party has
become a parody of itself so that's my
thought let's now talk about the most
vile moment ever in a state of the union
address
yesterday during joe biden's first
official state of the union address we
saw the most vile deplorable disgusting
moment that i've ever seen during any
state of the union
and it was the moment that radical
republican congresswoman lauren bobert
yelled out
13 of them died on your watch or
something like that when joe biden
started talking about veterans who have
died in the line of service and that
includes by the way
his deceased son who died of cancer and
in the middle of this moment
lauren bobert yells out and it is the
most disgusting moment of any state of
the union i can remember you've been
there
i've been in and out of iraq and
afghanistan over 40 times
these burn pits that incinerate waste
the waste of war medical
and hazards material jet fuel and so
much more
and they come home
many of the world's fittest and best
trained warriors in the world
never the same
headaches numbness dizziness
a cancer that would put them in a
flag-draped coffin
i know
one of those one of those soldiers was
my son major beau biden
i don't know for sure if the burn pit
that he lived near that his hooch was
near
in iraq and earlier than that in kosovo
is the cause of his brain cancer the
disease of so many other troops
but i am committed
to find out everything we can
these are the most
disgusting gross bad people these aren't
just bad legislators and there's some
debate as to whether both of the
outbursts were beau bert one of them
might have been marjorie taylor green
it's not they're both gross they both
turned their backs on biden when biden
walked in
i wouldn't want beau birder green
working at my local coffee shop at my
local library teaching school kids being
a nurse if i go into a hospital they are
the types of gross bad people that i
don't want anywhere near me in any
aspect of my life and i mean before this
the most kind of disrespectful state of
the union moment that i can recall
is when uh republican congressman joe
wilson yelled you lie at barack obama uh
let's review that there are also those
who claim that our reform efforts would
ensure illegal immigrants
this too is false
the reforms
the reforms i'm proposing would not
apply to those who are here illegal
[Music]
so that was considered disrespectful and
it was
it is nothing compared to lauren bobert
yelling out when joe biden is literally
talking about his son who died
um beaubert tweeted about this trying to
make it seem like her morals wouldn't
allow her to sit idly by tweeting when
biden said flag draped coffins i
couldn't stay silent i told him directly
he did it
he put 13 in there
our heroic service men and women deserve
so much better in a different era
a congresswoman shouting and heckling
the president at a state of the union
while he's talking about not just u.s
soldiers killed in action generally
but about his own deceased son
would be universally condemned across
the political spectrum starting with her
caucus leader and might even be censured
punished in some way
but these people have support the people
who like beaubert and greene they see
this just look online
go go you know look at all the typical
places look at the responses to their
own tweets
and they celebrate them for doing this
these are vile disgusting people
and if you don't think what they did is
shameful
you should be ashamed of yourself these
are disgusting individuals who have no
business doing anything involving public
service we're going to take a break find
me at deepakman on twitter we'll be
right back
one of our sponsors today is cheese
butter giving you 15
off i love this stuff cheese butter is a
delicious gourmet cheese melt that
ingeniously blends
four indulgent cheeses and aromatically
seasoned butter
all the ingredients the cheese the
butter the seasonings are sourced for
the highest quality you can really taste
that this was made with fresh simple
high shelf ingredients nothing
artificial
cheese on bread right i mean come on and
butter on bread
why wouldn't i love cheese butter put it
on french bread sourdough bagels english
muffin jewish rye
pumpernickel
sandwiches grilled cheese burgers baked
potatoes mac and cheese broccoli veggies
cheese butter is a business that
supports the david pakman show support
them their product is really fantastic
it's been a secret recipe in their
family for 50 years
taste it for yourself to really
understand what it's about
i don't think you'll be sorry
cheese butter is giving my audience 15
off when you go to cheesebutter.com
pacman
quite literally as joe biden was giving
his state of the union address last
night more and more news continued to
break and incredible things were
happening in russia and ukraine in
russia's continued invasion which by all
recent reports continues to push towards
kiev and we're wondering when will when
will the big attempt to take keefe take
place if at all all signs point to it
will at some point and one of the pieces
of the story that is just almost beyond
belief
is that an assassination attempt against
the president of ukraine zielinski has
been foiled and it has allegedly been
foiled at least in part thanks to some
members of russia's fsb its intelligence
service and if this is as reported and
now there are widespread reports of it
it is unbelievable axios reporting
zelensky assassination plot foiled
ukrainian authorities say okay
ukrainian national security and defense
council chief alexi danilov announced
during a briefing tuesday that ukrainian
forces foiled an assassination plot
against zelensky according to a telegram
post from ukrainian authorities
the big picture
according to the telegram message
danilov said that a unit of elite
chechen special forces known as
khadirovites had been behind the plot
and were subsequently eliminated okay
we are well aware of the special
operation that was to take place
directly directly by the khadirovites to
eliminate our president
ukrainian authorities had been tipped
off about the plot by members of
russia's federal security service who
don't support the war
danilov elaborated that the khadirovite
group had been divided into two with one
being destroyed in gossamell and the
other under fire
this story if true as told is truly
incredible we know that many russians
don't support the invasion of ukraine
that vladimir putin is carrying out we
we know that and many of them thousands
have been protesting hundreds have been
arrested we know that but what this
story if true points to
is that even deep
in the upper echelons or at least in
some of the top organizations like the
security service the fsb
there are not only dissenting voices but
voices that are not just neutrally
dissenting like i'm not going to say
anything but i don't like this but they
became aware of an assassination plot
against president zielenski and they
made sure that it was known by ukrainian
authorities and security officials so
that it could be foiled and apparently
it was
the other aspect of this of course is
you know we talked about the very
strange pictures many of them now
of vladimir putin sitting at tables with
his advisors and the table is 50 foot 50
feet long it reminds me of uh
um you know the old batman movie it's
one of the first movies i saw when i
moved to the us with jack nicholson and
michael keaton there's a scene where
bruce wayne takes i believe it's the kim
basinger character
home to his house and they're in this
extremely cold dining room and bruce
wayne says i don't even know that i've
been in this room before
and the table is crazy long and they end
up sitting next to each other because
the table's so absurdly long the tables
putin is sitting at are even longer and
one of the things we hypothesized was
could he be worried that even inside the
top brass his top advisors there could
be people who want to see him dead and
that's the reason for the separation not
covet or whatever else might be
maybe it is and if the fsb foiling the
plot story is true
um it would make perfect sense that that
would be something vladimir putin is
afraid of an incredible story
also interesting yesterday cnn was able
to get an interview
with president zielenski in his bunker
he's been in a bunker for some period of
time and occasionally exiting the bunker
to
record videos and do different things
that we have seen cnn's matthew chan
spoke with zolensky in the bunker about
what's going on with negotiations and
other things and it is incredible to see
you sent your delegation to meet the
russians for talks
did anything substantial come out of
that is there any hope
as the world watches for diplomacy they
decided they decided
uh
to begin to speak about this situation
and i want it i i really wanted and i
asked them so you have to speak first of
all you everybody has to
stop stop fighting and to go to that
point from
where
it it was beginning yes it began five
six two day six six days ago yes i think
there are principal things you can do it
and that is very important moment if you
do this and if those side is ready it
means that they are ready for the piece
the the level of
i've never been like a big zelinski fan
or anything like it but
the level of poise
that he is exhibiting
from a bunker
separated from his family
as
bombs are dropping
shelling is happening all over the
country
it is just incredible
if they don't ready it means that you're
just you know
just
[Music]
wasting time do you think you're wasting
your time or do you think they're ready
we'll see
just uh i i mean it is it is
unbelievable what uh is taking place
right now
and um the question around
the so-called negotiations is an
important question
we sort of just very casually talked
about well what is it russia would want
in such negotiations i imagine russia
would want to officially kind of see
ukraine give up on crimea
and probably give up on the donetsk and
luhansk regions that's that that's
probably something russia would want is
that something ukraine would be willing
to give it's hard to imagine
on the other hand i would imagine that
ukraine would want
russia to accept that if ukraine joins
nato or if ukraine joins the eu
it would not be opposed by russia or
seen as a sign of aggression or as a
justification for aggression by russia
and it's very hard to imagine that
that's something that russia would
accept as well so they talk about
negotiations
it's in a practical sense
very difficult to imagine
what sort of agreement there could be
that would be satisfactory to both sides
but that's why there's such a thing as
professional diplomacy and professional
uh negotiators we will continue seeing
that there's sort of the two tracks
there's the we are looking at doing some
negotiation on the border with belarus
and there's
at some point putin's going to make his
play for kiev and that could be at any
time and it's not obvious that ukrainian
forces and volunteers are going to be
able to repel the russian forces so the
next 24-48 hours could be key uh we're
going to take a quick break the clips
from that zelensky interview
which is very much worth watching will
be on our instagram which you can find
at david pakman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpacman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
today we're going to be speaking with
heath druzen who's creator and host of
the podcast extremely american produced
in partnership with post-industrial
media and boise state public radio you
can find extremely american everywhere
you get podcasts uh heath it's really
great having you on today i appreciate
it
great to be here thanks
so um you know it certainly since the
trump riots and even before that we've
been covering
militia groups so-called militia groups
for for a long period of time you
covered
the pennsylvania volunteer militia which
is sort of adjacent to some of the other
groups maybe people in my audience are
familiar with can you talk a little bit
about how did you get interested in this
how did you start covering them what are
some of their views how would we
characterize these groups
yeah i mean i've been covering the
militia movement and kind of the the
broader uh far-right movement for a
number of years now um what kind of got
me started on this podcast is i started
seeing them get a lot more politically
active kind of come out of the woods
come out of the mountains and be much
more
visible in everyday life
the pennsylvania volunteers
they are an interesting group because
they're led by a guy named christian
yangling and he played a pretty um he
played a pretty notable role in
charlottesville in 2017
and your listeners uh probably recognize
that that was the the white supremacist
rally
in charlottesville that also drew in a
lot of militia groups who said they were
there to basically keep the peace
between
right-wing uh protesters and left-wing
counter-protesters some people
questioned that um so yingling was there
he actually got sued and
agreed to never come back to
charlottesville with a militia so he's
uh he's been in the news
he's a very sort of colorful character
so i got to know him through that
and
um i had been doing a number of
interviews with him and trying to get in
on his training because i i wanted to
give listeners of my podcast extremely
american i wanted to give them
a real feel for what it's like to be
at a training with a militia what they
do
get there on the gun range with them
so that's what brought me out there it
took me a while to get their trust but
they eventually
let me come to their monthly training
which is deep in the pennsylvania woods
kind of out in these rolling mountains
in western pennsylvania this sort of
classic site you would imagine a militia
training happening at yeah so that's
what that's what got me there and um you
know we've spoken to people who who have
i don't want to use the term infiltrated
but who have been sort of like granted
access to different types of extremists
and different different journalists and
reporters take different approaches in
terms of whether
they just remain extraordinarily neutral
in terms of their opinion of what it is
that they're observing or whether they
are sort of engaged in conversations
about their views as to what what these
groups do
what's the dynamic like when you're with
these folks in terms of how they see you
and and sort of what the conversations
are like
yeah i mean so if you if you listen to
the podcast um and especially episode
one with this group what you'll hear is
i let them tell their own story
but you know i i don't i don't just sit
on the sidelines if somebody says
something outlandish i challenge them
yeah so um i'll give you an example you
know christian yingling at one point
he's talking about being between he went
to a trump rally where they were counter
protesters and he was standing with his
guys between the left and right wing
protesters
well he talks about the story about how
he was basically trying to get the
left-wing protesters to back up now
they're in a public park right uh he has
no authority there he's a private
citizen and he's telling them to back up
and you know i and he's telling them
basically if you don't back up i'm gonna
break your leg to one of the guys and
and that's you know that's where i do
step in and i'm like well now hold on
under whose authority do you do that and
so there's back and forth like that um i
do want to let them tell their own story
because i think
that's more interesting for a listener
than me just spouting off but certainly
i'm not going to let something like that
just sort of twist in the wind um so
there's some kind of fun back and forth
about that
about january 6th about donald trump um
so yeah you know i'll challenge people
when i feel like that is appropriate but
i do also want people to to hear their
viewpoint because i think understanding
these groups is much more important than
than slamming them for example just uh
just to sort of feel good at the
individual level you know i've spoken to
a lot of former hate group members
including kkk and some other groups and
the one theme that is present in all of
their stories was
they were sucked in because of a sort of
personal vulnerability
of their situation that came often from
sort of like the prototypical absent or
broken family or or lack of direction
from parents it's like a very similar
story that they all tell is that
a common backstory in the folks that you
see in the militia groups or is that
different
so i would say there's a little bit a
little bit of yes and no there i've
certainly met people who fit that mold i
think with militia groups though because
most of them um they're they're not
explicitly racist and a lot of them
actually will at least
outwardly reject that i think they have
a bit of broader appeal
um i think i think when you're talking
about like explicitly white supremacist
groups i i think that recruitment's a
little tougher and you really have to
to try harder with the militia groups
they try to tell they try to have a
bigger tent i guess you can say so what
i do find though is people who are very
disaffected with
what's happening in america um they
might be uncomfortable with a changing
country they might be uncomfortable with
increasing diversity they may not say it
like that but they will talk about
certain things like transgender rights
come up a lot and that makes a lot of
people in this movement uncomfortable
they'll talk about critical race theory
now whether or not that's actually a
real thing in american schools you know
that's obviously something that people
are debating but there is a discomfort
with a changing america that draws
people in and i think certainly donald
trump's rise to power and some of the
things he said made them feel more
empowered than they have and i think
made them feel more comfortable coming
out in the open as opposed to just
training out in the woods
uh is there either is there a notable
undertone of anti-semitism in these
groups
i would actually say no um i am a jewish
reporter um i you know i i did not feel
that directly um i did speak to one very
prominent jewish member of the three
percent militia in washington state um
he figures prominently in episode three
and we talk a little bit about his
background
now is that to say that there is not a
strain of anti-semitism no i also ran
into some really offensive stuff where
people would talk about they would
compare covet protocols to nazism now is
that directly anti-semitism we can
debate that but it's certainly very
offensive i think to a lot of people
so
i i would say explicitly no you do get
that undercurrent with some people and i
think you do get some sort of explaining
away of stuff
how prominent is the presence of law
enforcement current or former and
military current informer in your
experience in these groups
i run into a lot of ex-military in these
groups um i also run into a lot of
people who kind of are in the uh you
know i wish i would have served kind of
mold um but you do run into a lot of
veterans um you run into some law
enforcement it gets kind of murky
there's there's certainly some law
enforcement that have been supportive
there's a whole sheriff's movement
called the constitutional sheriff's
movement and they have elected sheriffs
all over the country joe arpaio in
arizona was part of that
and they're very friendly to militias
now you also get law enforcement who are
dead set against them because they see
their anti-government rhetoric is also
anti-law enforcement so it's a very
mixed bag but i would say the veteran
part of it that is a robust part of the
military or the militia movement do the
militia groups get along with each other
or do they see each other as competitors
or they believe they aren't
you know do they have problems with the
ideologies of some of the other groups
so that's a great question
this might not be surprising but
anti-government movements are not very
good at centralized control so there is
a lot of bickering back and forth and a
lot of infighting um and frankly just
some some honest disagreements where
you'll have groups that absolutely
will disavow um another group including
different three percent groups
there's a group in georgia that has a
confederate flag in their logo and some
of the more
some of the some of the other three
percenters in the west you know they'll
look to them and say we absolutely want
nothing to do with those guys they're
racist and we reject them so it's a
mixed bag they do come together over two
things a radical view of limited
government
and pretty much absolutist gun rights
any restriction on gun rights they see
as a red line i would say almost every
militia group agrees on those two things
what is the um or let's see how i can
phrase this
there's the fear among observers of some
of these groups that at some point
they're gonna do like their big thing
you know like the the
you think about jim jones and jonestown
and eventually there was like the mass
suicide of the 950 people in south
america and it was sort of like the
culmination of the entire thing and
there's the fear that some equivalent
not not killing themselves necessarily
but there's the equivalent that they're
building to some kind of big event do
you get the sense that that's the
eventual goal or are they there more of
as like as a constant low-grade
protection again as they see it against
the tyranny and oppression of the
government or whatever the case may be
without planning like some big event
i think what you're seeing is um and
what i get into
in extremely american is the shift away
from that kind of thinking
more to
hey we have this moment where we've got
more mainstream support let's try to
change government from the inside
there's a lot of younger leaders who i
would say are much more politically
savvy than the old guard from the
michigan militia and those kind of
groups and you know they're they're
targeting their local school boards
their library boards they're picking off
state senate and state uh legislature
seats
um so that's not to say we couldn't have
that i mean we've seen it we've seen it
at least twice we saw a cliven bundy's
ranch where all those militia guys were
pointing weapons at federal agents that
could have gone quickly and we saw it in
oregon where ammon bundy cliven's son
had an arm stand off of his own now we
could totally see that again i think a
lot of these guys are much more focused
on trying to bring government to the
right as opposed to you know having an
armed confrontation even though when you
ask them they will admit they are
simultaneously training to fight against
the government and kind of trying to be
a part of it yeah well so that was going
to be my next thing which is you talked
about the presence of military veterans
there's
in hypothetical discussions about what
might happen if one of these groups
really tried something big there's the
reality that eventually they might be
confronting not just police but if they
really wreaked enough havoc the national
guard or they would sort of be against
the military but they are made up they
have a significant former military
presence how do they conceive of that of
the idea that ultimately the force that
might stop them is the one that many of
them were once a part of
right and that's something you can't
escape
when i talk to
militia members and leaders about that
often they kind of deflect at first
but
when i press them they admit yes i mean
that you can't talk about fighting the
government without the possibility
and really the almost probability if you
fight the government that your guns are
going to be pointed at law enforcement
and or
troops
now what they'll say if you press them
is that you know righteous righteous
troops and law enforcement will step
aside because the battle will be
righteous for the militia guys but it's
absolutely something that hangs in the
background and you can't avoid it and
when you look at those standoffs
they were against law enforcement and
they weren't against troops but they
were against law enforcement and in the
case of the oregon standoff you know
there was a deadly deadly shootout um
and a man got killed so it's not it's
not theoretical that could happen and it
has happened in terms of the political
alignment uh when it comes to
democrats republicans etc i mean you
made it clear they want to move the
government to the right their most
important issues certainly align more
with the republican party than the
democratic party but like is there any
political diversity within these groups
yeah and i also get into that in the
podcast because i i think the political
angle on these groups it makes them so
much more interesting now
i mean i should say yes and no uh are
any of them democrats that i've met no
um do they have diverse political views
yeah yeah yeah there there is a
diversity of views some are more
libertarian sort of live and let live
some of them are really much more sort
of fundamentalist far right groups and i
would say more of them are
are of that ilk
and that's why they're targeting school
boards they talk a lot about critical
race theory and culture war issues
and i think that's a big change from the
1990s in the 1990s they might have been
very conservative but they were very
much pox on both parties they're all the
same
these guys today they're much more
involved in republican politics and i
think that's a really important shift
because they've sort of picked sides in
a way
that they didn't in the past they just
saw all government as bad before
right that that's interesting and
there's also the question as to
how responsible donald trump is for that
and whether the political activism may
fade to some degree if trumpism fades i
mean that's a question we've had about
the general voter who never voted before
trump was pulled in to vote for trump
and then now
it's unclear how engaged they stay
right yeah and i think i think that's
the the one of the biggest questions
hanging over this movement now i think
they were on the rise before trump um i
saw them rising before trump but they
were they were super charged by trump
they saw somebody at the highest echelon
of power
um really they saw him as supportive now
they talk a lot about basically taking
that momentum and continuing that kind
of trumpism without trump
um i think we're gonna see i think i
think that's that's a real open question
i think these midterm elections might
have a lot to do with it
um but they're trying to keep that
momentum up right now
and i i do think we'll see if trump
jumps back in 2024 but without him they
do potentially lose momentum
um but i guess we'll just have to see
how far right um the right wing of
american politics has gone
without a doubt yeah no that's it's
without a doubt an open question that
we're all sort of anxiously waiting
waiting to start getting some answers to
uh the podcast is extremely american
creator and host of the podcast heath
drewsen has been uh talking to us about
his investigative work heath really
appreciate your time today
thanks so much i appreciate you having
me on
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon
go to patreon.com david pakman show
where you can get access to behind the
scenes videos the daily bonus show the
commercial free daily show as well as
special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow one of the things many
of you have been writing to me and
asking over the last couple of weeks of
the russian invasion of ukraine has been
some version of hey david why do so many
american right-wingers love vladimir
putin
and this is not a topic that has uh uh
slipped
the minds of many on the left who have
been wondering and asking about it
there's actually a couple of good
articles that you guys can check out one
such article by arwa madawi is an
opinion piece in the guardian called why
does putin have superfans among the u.s
right wing the sub-headline being the
russian leader is an autocrat
with a homophobic and misogynistic
worldview no wonder he's admired by so
many republicans pointing to essentially
um the the uh
governing and cultural similarities
between putin and what many
right-wingers would like to see
robert reich wrote in the guardian an
opinion piece called putinism is
breeding in the heart of repub of the
republican party make no mistake putin's
authoritarian neo-fascism
has rooted itself in america the cold
war has already come home
there are different reasons why
different right-wingers find putin to be
an appealing and interesting figure we
saw the video which i'm not going to
play again from the weekend at afpak
afpak was the openly white nationalist
counterpart to cpac
and at afpac one of their leaders nick
fuentes talked about um
russia has what russia has going for it
is uh young white men and they started
chanting putin putin putin and so for
some people what they like about putin
is
white
homophobic
trumpian reactionary
probably anti-semitic to some degree
uh leader
and putin antenato and trump antenato up
until two days ago remember that two
days
i mean this is so stupid but two days
ago trump started taking credit for nato
now that nato is seen as good because
it's uh on the side of ukraine now trump
after trying to crush nato when he was
president now trump says nato is good
but
up until before two days ago uh donald
trump and putin both very much anti-nato
and when you step back russia is sort of
what many of these republicans would
like to see the united states become
and what i mean by that is
they
like the idea
of
the authoritarian strong man gets to
decide who's president i mean that's
that's what putin essentially does
and it's what trump tried to do so that
that's very appealing to many trump
republicans
barely any
serious worker protections in russia
barely any environmental protections in
russia the rich can get away with paying
barely any taxes
through their cronyistic connections to
leadership
the government just openly tells media
what to do and they have a massive state
media apparatus that does their bidding
trump's trumpists and trump love that
stuff
um open homophobia and other uh uh
phobias that in the united states at
least to some degree you're still kind
of looked at as that's not really
appropriate if you just come out and say
a lot of the stuff
um a lot of uh
[Music]
um
sort of state assets that are privatized
controlled by oligarchs and
people get cushy contracts because
they're close to government yeah all
that type of corruption
and cultural reactionary
infrastructure
that the united states
doesn't
fully have that many republicans would
like to see it have exists in russia it
exists in russia you can even kind of
make it even simpler
change would be bad
and keeping right wing white people in
control is good
i mean that that's like you could even
simplify it even more and you quickly
understand why there are so many right
wingers who love what is happening in uh
russia i think um
one other thing that's important to
mention
is that not everybody in the trumpian
republican party openly supports putin a
lot of them
don't but they'll kind of talk around
the edges about
making sure that democracy works as
intended which remember is the same type
of code that the putin people use in
russia to justify their subjugation of
democracy to control elections it's it's
really really similar if you look at the
language and you look at the goals and
you look at the political orientation so
it's a serious topic
um it's not just oh a lot of these
trumpists are enamored with putin yeah
some of them are some of them not so
openly but the degree to which russia is
the image
of what we would get here if the
trumpists got their way whether or not
they say positive things about putin
should really scare all of us
mitch mcconnell is the senate minority
leader
he um
is a pretty horrible guy
yesterday
during joe biden's state of the union
when joe biden talked about his job
creation record
mcconnell didn't seem to like it he just
looked comatose almost like he had bad
had some bad oysters uh before before
the event
he was given the opportunity yesterday
to actually condemn what donald trump
said about vladimir putin calling the
invasion of ukraine genius and calling
the invasion smart and he didn't do it
mcconnell's very willing to say putin's
bad but he won't condemn trump for what
he said
you've long been critical of president
vladimir putin was it a mistake for the
former president to praise putin as very
savvy smart is ukraine's strategy genius
what president putin is
is a ruthless thug
who's just invaded
invaded another sovereign country
and killed thousands of innocent people
that's what president putin is so yeah
mcconnell sounds very very sick but what
he's saying
is
i'm not going to say anything about
donald trump when donald trump said
putin's savvy
genius smart for what he did putin's bad
but i'm not going to condemn trump and i
almost at this point wonder why because
trump regularly attacks mitch mcconnell
mitch mcconnell did appear on fox
yesterday and blamed joe biden for
what's happening in ukraine which is
another popular one among the right
speech tonight he goes into the chamber
this evening with a 37 percent approval
number what do you think he needs to do
tonight in order to galvanize the united
states and to as you said earlier uh
make a big course correction what did
you mean by that
well look uh he
he's in this kind of shape because he
deserves to be in this kind of shape
raging inflation
uncontrolled
border in my view
too late to deter
putin and we've taken some of these
steps earlier
this might not have happened and the
president's in a tough position because
he deserves to be in a tough position
now understand that you really can't win
with these people because if joe biden
and and remember it's not just the u.s
but if joe biden and other european
allies had started the sanctions and the
flight closures and these things early
these are the republicans who under
trump were saying we should be getting
along with putin there's no reason for
unnecessary or extraordinary hostilities
with putin so it's a no win because if
biden had started these these moves
earlier
he would have been criticized for
doing too much too quickly and being
overly aggressive
now he's being criticized for not moving
quickly enough and these are just bad
faith actors that's that's the reality i
don't believe
joe biden's response has been perfect
and i've criticized the response where i
felt that it needs criticism but these
are just bad faith critiques now just
for comparison again i don't love the
guy but just as a comparison for a
different type of republican
here was mitt romney asked about biden's
handling and he gives a much more normal
response
about biden has done some things well
it's not biden's fault that putin
invaded another country but you could do
better this is like a more normal
republican response i want to go back in
time a little bit senator do you think
it was a mistake for president biden to
rule out u.s troops on the ground
instead of trying to use what's known as
strategic ambiguity to deter vladimir
putin from invading in the first place
well there really wouldn't have been an
ambiguity we don't have the kind of
troop strength uh and and material of
war in the region to be uh to be a
serious threat at that point uh look the
the uh
the bite administration has done some
things very well and some things not so
well the not so well side is they
continued the policy of prior
administrations not to provide the
defensive weapons ukraine needed that
was the mistake the positive thing was
sharing our intelligence with our allies
and combining uh our efforts with our
allies look we used to be 40 of the
world economy today we're about half of
that and and so for us to have the kind
of economic clout we used to have back
in the 50s and 60s and 70s we really do
need to combine with our allies and
that's something president biden has
done extraordinarily well so understand
that that's sort of like i know it's
weird to hear that like to some people
that might be like well that if you
didn't know who it was he'd be like that
must be a democrat no republican would
say that joe biden is actually doing
things that well
there was a point at which more normal
republicans would say oh okay hey you
know what
your criticism of biden isn't a good one
and here's why and joe biden
mitt romney explained that
on some things joe biden has done a
really good job
and here are the things i would have
done differently that at one point was
actually normal and for all of our
disagreements with mitt romney if romney
was the worst of the republican party
this country would be far better off
than with people like than we are with
people like mcconnell
bobert
green
cawthorne gomer and all of these you
know gates and all of these other uh
lunatics so um it would be great if we
could go back in that direction
republicans aren't incentivized to do
that and case in point someone like mitt
romney is not a celebrity republican in
the sense that the ones that get
attention are the radical crazies the
ones that are willing to do things like
josh hawley did on january 6 2021 people
like ted cruz etc it's the cartoons
and uh i mean listen i'm not giving the
republican party advice the country
would be better off if romney was the
worst of the party sadly romney's the
best of the party not the worst of the
party we have a voicemail number and
that number is 2192 david p here's a
caller who says i was wrong about
something i think they're wrong let's
take a listen
david uh you made a mistake on your show
the uh today
um
you said that
rents would of course would go up
because everything else is going up
but i own a house
and
my mortgage does not go up just because
everything else is going up i'm still
paying the same amount for my mortgage
yeah if i want to go get a new mortgage
that would be another thing
but
market you know
mortgages don't go up just because
everything else goes up okay so first of
all if you have an adjustable rate
mortgage if rates go up then your
mortgage will go up but the caller is
confused the point i made and that we
talked about is when home prices go up
and the way you see home prices go up is
they sell for more i'm talking about
transactions when you start seeing
houses and apartment buildings transact
for more money
those increased sale prices are then
reflected in rents i know that if you
already own a house
then the the fact that other houses that
are being sold sell for more doesn't
affect your mortgage but the point was
we would expect that when home sale
prices go up and this is the homes that
are being sold not you just living in
your house sir when home sale when home
prices go up
then you see rents reflect those
increased sale prices with higher rents
that was the point
i wasn't wrong we don't need to issue a
correction i would be right here issuing
one if i needed to okay on the bonus
show today
more western companies are suffering
ties with russia we'll tell you which
ones the major league baseball season is
already delayed and we'll talk about the
labor dispute that's going on and we
will talk about primary results from
texas where yes beto o'rourke won the
democratic gubernatorial primary
incumbent greg abbott won the republican
president gubernatorial primary we'll
talk about what that race is shaping up
to be and much more on two days bonus
show sign up at
joinpackman.com and we will see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors cheese butter is
the delicious gourmet cheese melt that
blends four indulgent cheeses and
seasoned butter i love this stuff
perfect on bread bagel sandwiches
veggies and more you'll get fifteen
percent off at cheesebutter.com
pacman the link is down below